the world's best guides to non-fiction
books come from our sponsor short form
short form offers comprehensive coverage
to thousands of top non-fiction books so
you can learn more faster unlike other
summary Services their guides provide
valuable insights counter arguments and
analyzes for a well-rounded
understanding of the topic try it free
and get 25 off using my link below
yes Donald Trump is getting arrested
later but we start today with economic
news we'll get to this truck the Trump
stuff we'll have time to discuss it
tomorrow let's start with economic news
inflation has now dropped to its lowest
point in two years and as you all know I
don't like to play politics with these
economic indicators I don't play
politics with debt and deficit we have
to look at it for what it is and if you
do that you will then have no choice but
to laugh at the way that Fox News
covered this Yahoo finance reports
inflation consumer prices in May Rose at
slowest annual rate since April of 2021
that's in fact more than two years it's
25 almost 26 months the Consumer Price
Index revealed headline inflation Rose
0.1 percent over the last month and four
percent over the price entire year in
May a Slowdown from April's 0.4 percent
month over month increase and 4.9
percent annual gain both measures
roughly in line with Economist forecasts
so we have a chart that you can see and
of course you see this massive inflation
Spike uh that started um right when
covid started essentially it has now
come down to levels that are still
higher than what the U.S has seen but
are equivalent to what we saw
um in 2011 lower than what we saw during
the recession in 2008 similar to numbers
we had in 2006 similar to numbers in
2001 lower than numbers in 91. so you
start to see that we are now in an
inflation range that is a little bit
higher than what we have historically
said is the target
but are very reasonable inflation
numbers is this a surprise it is not I
don't have any special predictive
ability but anybody paying attention to
the trends we saw an increase in the
rate of inflation
we saw a decrease in the increase of
that rate and then the next thing you
would expect is an actual decrease my
thought was that by the end of this
summer we would be somewhere in the four
to five range we may even what once we
get June's numbers in July or July's
numbers in August we may actually see
inflation down into the high threes
which is even lower than I thought it
might be or it might stay level right
around this four percent important to
understand a couple of different things
and I always explain these things number
one when people see the number four
percent very often they think prices
went up four percent in may they did not
four percent is the inflation over the
last 12 months and what happens when you
get a new month's worth of data
is that in that year indicator you drop
that 13 month ago number and you add the
latest one so let me give you an example
the number we got last month in May
told us what was inflation from April 22
to April 23. now that we have the main
numbers we update the 12-month indicator
and we now know what was inflation from
May 22 to May 23. it's a trailing
12-month indicator number two many
people aren't aware that based on the
standards that we have for our economies
and how we think about the economy the
goal is roughly two to three percent
inflation now you might say David why
why would we want inflation and it's
important to understand this you can
critique it by saying this is not
sustainable long term as an economy
because we can't have indefinite growth
which I would engage with you on but the
reason that a little bit of inflation is
considered good is if you have too much
inflation as we understand life becomes
unaffordable for people it can cause
spending to stop because people can't
afford things and it can cause a
recession that's if we have two much
inflation you might say well but
wouldn't deflation be good then price is
going down sounds good people can afford
things if you start seeing deflation
where things get cheaper it also causes
people not to spend in businesses not to
invest why would that be if you expect
that things will be cheaper in the
future either as an individual consumer
thinking about buying a car or as a
business thinking about doing an
expansion building a new Warehouse or
whatever the case may be if you think it
will be cheaper in the future you would
wait that waiting is a decline in
economic activity which then trickles
down and can lead to layoffs and okay so
that's what we call a deflationary
spiral that's why a little bit of
inflation is considered good that little
bit of inflation is what encourages
people to buy now rather than later
but they can still afford right now and
often a little bit of inflation is in
parallel with wage growth so that's like
the general economic view now how did
Fox News react to this news well they
think there may be too many jobs they
are pulling the labor shortage Line This
is Maria Bartiromo and Republican
Congressman buddy Carter just this
morning we will also hear from um
treasury secretary Janet Yellen today
representative Earl buddy Carter talk to
us about what you're expecting there
because the treasury secretary uh when
we first started seeing this spike in
inflation says it was transitory what
are your thoughts on how she'll explain
uh where we're going from here
well I'm sure she'll make it out to be
as as good as she can but at the same
time we are far from out of trouble here
yes I agree the FED May pause next this
month and may not raise interest rates
but that doesn't mean they're not going
to raise him back in July we've still
got some serious problems in our economy
right labor shortage last night I had
dinner with a group of Engineers and
they were telling me we need help we
need Engineers one company said they had
1700 employees they'd hire 200 today if
they could find them we still got high
interest rates in the lobby this morning
I was talking to a young lady who said
you know I wanted to buy a new car but I
just can't afford it right now it's so
high inflation interest rates those are
the type of things that we've still got
to work on in this economy and you know
Janet Yellen will paint a pretty picture
yeah all right these people really are
pathetic the argument he's making is
there are so many businesses desperate
to hire people that it is a terrible
economy the economy must be doing
terribly because so many businesses are
saying hey let's hire because we have
demand for our products and services now
let I'll be very clear with you let's
talk about Labor shortage a labor
shortage happens when demand for workers
in a particular industry for example
exceeds the supply of workers available
with the skills required willing to work
at the wage rate that is being offered
labor shortages can be a sign of a good
economy or they can be troubling labor
shortages can have positive or negative
effects on an economy depending on the
type of Labor shortage the duration the
severity and so a labor shortage even if
that's what they are calling it is not
necessarily a bad thing for the economy
it might just signal really strong
demand for goods and services it might
create incentives to innovate and to
increase efficiency and it might mean
that employers need to offer higher
wages they love talking about the market
and supply of demand supply and demand
and what a labor shortage May signal
particularly when you're at full
employment essentially is that
businesses might need to pay a little
bit more so just saying labor shortage
isn't an argument and it is certainly
not an argument when people like Maria
Bartiromo and what was this guy's name
Buddy Carter are the ones making that
argument understand that there is no
economic indicator right now
that signals a weak economy there is
just none and we're going to continue
covering that fox news's Sean Hannity
thought that he would bring on
Democratic California governor Gavin
Newsom and make him look dumb by getting
him to talk about Biden and getting him
to talk about California and Gavin
Newsom proved everything I have been
saying about him for the last several
months you know Gavin Newsom is not the
most Progressive but Gavin Newsom
strikes exactly the right tone demeanor
and temperament that the Democratic
party could use more of this is a guy
who every time I see him interviewed
proves that he is a serious potential
future Contender for the Democratic
presidential nomination now would he be
attacked for being the liberal
California
yeah he would uh would he have answers
to those claims he would look at this
interview and look at how Newsome
crushes Sean Hannity on his own show
starting here with economic issues this
is a clinic this is when you have
trainings done of democratic candidates
this is what you need to be showing for
our president I have great confidence in
his
face I think his policies are failing ah
chip sack science act do you oppose that
I will tell you on every measure from
the economy inflation borders energy uh
National Security he's missing an
accident let's talk about them in order
wait but I want to challenge the premise
Kennedy wants to list them but he
doesn't want to go through one by one
typical the economy 13.1 million jobs
he's created more these opposed Cova
jobs you know that well I mean that's an
artificial number then let me just let
me circulate this as an as an
opportunity to engage civilly on this
okay Fair Point your president Donald
Trump lost 2.6 million jobs during his
four years we've created 13.1 million
fine you can maintain a coveted frame
how about the fact that Joe Biden's
created more jobs six times more jobs
than the previous three Republican
presidents you're buying are you going
to tell me that the average family where
we have two-thirds of Americans now
living paycheck to paycheck it was 70
under Trump that's just freaking
brilliant guys guys that this is exact
they love to cite these numbers
two-thirds of families are now paycheck
to paycheck of course it's not actually
two-thirds two-thirds would be 66.6
percent the number is actually in the
low 60s so Hannity rounds up and Newsome
points out that number is down like
seven points from when Trump was
President this is exactly how you have
to fight these guys
we had the lowest unemployment rate for
every demographic and they are even
lower now we have the lowest
and you and I are living with the lowest
unemployment we have in our lifetime
every demographic and the economy black
unemployment's record low under Joe
Biden okay we had historic low after
historic low under Donald Trump and it
is even better now this is how you don't
back down from these bullies two of the
best messaging folks I'm talking from a
communication standpoint right now okay
we're not doing a policy analysis are on
the left are Gavin Newsom and Pete boot
Edge okay this is how you have to fight
these people now obviously this alone
won't win you elections I'm not
delusional but this is how you do it
here is the topic of inflation and
Newsome is just barreling through
Hannity question I'm answering the ones
in order brought up the economy on the
economy let's talk about the economy
inflation stubborn around the globe
let's let's but let's talk about
inflation it's down 40 since last summer
10 months in a row 4.9 percent he was
just and by the way now down to four
percent this interview was from last
night so that's why they don't have that
data yet UK prime minister it's 6.9 is
that because of Biden's I think violence
economic and energy policy directly
impacted the UK's inflation no or the
fact that France is 5.5 or Germany's at
six years on inflation we're moving in
the right direction folks he's
steamrolling him this it's stunning
Hannity is Hannity is lost control
and he doesn't have the facts on his
hand on the issue of the border security
inherited 1.4 inflation it went up to a
40-year high and 40-year high globally
globally because you just brought it so
you were making an excuse for Trump's
dismal jobs record ready to
coverage relationship to inflation this
is folks this is this is textbook
Hannity wants to have it both ways yes
Trump lost 2.6 million jobs but that was
because of covid but what about high
inflation under Biden well hold on
that's globally because of covid oh no
then it's not then covet isn't the
explanation Newsome is almost perfect on
this Hannity pulls the Biden's weak
thing here is Newsom I think he's a man
of decency and character I'm really
proud of the president I'm proud of what
he's accomplished he's strong enough to
be president that's I'm strong enough
talking about what he just did to
McCarthy he ran circle look at the vote
card I wouldn't vote for it exactly
Kevin got played by the president United
States I'm for results did you did you
see what just happened did you see that
Hannity is agreeing with Newsom newsom's
making the argument if Biden is so weak
how did he have McCarthy wrapped around
his finger and got McCarthy to do
exactly what he wanted and Hannity goes
I wouldn't vote have voted for that bill
that McCarthy voted for that's the point
if Biden is so weak how did he perfectly
engineer McCarthy into doing what he
wanted him to do here just a couple more
of these and this we could do this all
day here's Newsom explaining hey you
know California actually works pretty
well yeah things are expensive because
people want to go there it's called
supply and demand but California is
working for pretty damn well in 2021
California 7.8 percent of GDP GDP growth
in this country one of the fastest
growing economies anywhere on planet
Earth this state continues to be the
Temple of the American economy 25.6 of
All American jobs came from this state
in April and the last two fiscal years
we enjoyed
177.7 billion dollars in operating
surpluses we're on our way to be the
fourth largest economy Eat Your Heart
Out Germany in the world number one in r
d Venture Capital more scientists
researchers more Nobel laureates more
patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America with all due
respect Florida doesn't even come close
eat your heart out of Texas California
continues to be appreciate dominant
economic and for them I promised you
before this interview I would let you
give full answers that's a full answer
thank you yeah it is and yeah I mean
when you can't when you can't argue the
facts Hannity has no choice but to say
thank you for at least answering the
questions and here lastly is um uh he
knew some just humiliating Ron DeSantis
they were told they had jobs they told
they were going to get certain court
dates changed they were dropped off they
knocked on the door and they left and
there was not coordinated I mean what
kind of Faith tradition everything else
there was a video of humanization of the
people getting on the because they were
all lied to and told and they were being
taken care of everything's going to be
great I would be proud and happy then
then because by the way I have the RFP
because they landed in your Sanctuary
State you're going to take care of them
they should be happy look we'll we'll
deal with the car come on this
California I know it's called okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course we
have this okay I'm a border state Rhonda
Santos is not I know he's desperate to
get into the accident because a lot of
ply Donald Trump is going to clean is it
there's a Joe Biden DeSantis belly flop
do you you will clean his clock I don't
have a Christmas attention and he set
this up months ago by doing an RFP I
have the contractor okay my question he
tried to hire saying he was going to
send people to California this is a
stunt it's embarrassing it's not
pathetic I I just did not I think he did
the right thing his State's not a
sanctuary he did the right thing by by
flying migrants around even though I
can't explain why folks this is a
formidable political force and this is
not about cheerleading Newsome as the
epitome of the progressive candidate
this is about a model for the Next
Generation Democratic movement that
better knows how to deal with these
would-be bullies if if you didn't know
any better you'd think that was Gavin
newsom's show and that he was allowing
Hannity to say a few things things which
by the way didn't make a lot of sense
excellent job by Gavin Newsom
when there's a non-fiction book I just
don't have the time to read having a
summary of the book is really valuable
several different platforms out there
will summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics the
that's why I love short form short form
has every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at Short form.com Pacman
the link is down below
2024 Republican presidential candidate
Chris Christie did a CNN Town Hall last
night and he again proved he is really
the only serious Republican presidential
candidate I tell you this with no fear
or hesitation because it appears as
though Chris Christie has absolutely no
chance of winning that nomination he's
making too much sense he's willing to
criticize Donald Trump he answers
questions when they are asked of him I
will be the first to say Chris Christie
from 2016 to 2020 seemed to support most
of what Trump did and for that I think
he is horrible but if you compare him
and contrast him with the other
presidential candidates including Donald
Trump and Rhonda Sanctus and others the
Sanctus DeSantis and now I'm doing it a
running for the 2024 Republican
nomination this is the only serious
person and he actually could do a good
job in debating Joe Biden because he is
intelligent he's willing to answer
questions he's direct check out this
clip from last night's Town Hall Chris
Christie said saying they're blaming
everybody but Trump for this indictment
what about blaming Trump for the things
he did and we're in a situation where
there are people in my own party who are
blaming doj
how about blame him right he did it he
kept he took documents he wasn't
supposed to take he kept it when they
asked him back for them they got a grand
jury subpoena he refused to comply they
raided his home finally because he
refused to comply that all the things
were brought on himself as was this
indicted this is accurate what about
blaming the person who did the thing and
if you look in the comments to these
clips you see all these Maga people
saying Chris Christie is a rhino he's
not serious no one's taking him
seriously it is true that because Maga
has taken over the Republican Party the
one guy who actually makes some sense
and is more in line with the Mitt Romney
John McCain type Republicans seems to
have no shot now Steve Schmidt said last
week in our interview that he actually
thinks Chris Christie does have a shot
we will see here is Chris Christie
weighing in on the indictment itself I
want to ask you about the indictments
that we've seen yesterday former
Attorney General Bill Barr called the
indictment quote very damning and he
said if even half of it is true then
he's toast your former U.S attorney is
he right
it is a very tight very detailed
evidence-laden uh indictment and the
contact in there is is awful
I mean put aside taking the documents in
the first place
but then when you start getting asked
Anderson in May of 21
nicely with a letter from the archivist
saying could you please give it back
and you ignore it ignore it ignore it
then they come with a grand jury
subpoena and then according to the
indictment you tell your lawyers tell
them we don't have anything even though
you have dozens and dozens of boxes of
material
um that's obstruction of justice if it's
true and so I think the former Attorney
General is absolutely right this is an
actual proper legal analysis from a
prosecutor who is not so blinded by
partisanship and he also has an
incentive to criticize Trump obviously
Chris Christie again making the point at
another moment we blame everybody but
ourselves for our losses we should blame
the fact that Trump is a loser and he
lost everything for us an argument I've
been making for a while now it makes me
feel even more important
I'm just telling you
I've known him for 22 years
the only thing he understands is force
the only thing he understands is coming
right at him and making your case
and if these other candidates don't want
to do it the American people and
Republican primary voters have to start
to understand this
when did it when did we get to the point
we're always playing our adversaries for
the weakness of our candidates right oh
it's the Democrats fault it's doj's
fault it's this person's fault it's the
media's fault how bad is his
he hasn't won a damn thing since 2016.
three-time loser
2018 we lost the house 2020 we lost the
White House we lost the United States
Senate a couple weeks later in 2021 and
in 2022 we lost two more governorships
another senate seat and barely took the
House of Representatives when Joe Biden
had the most incompetent first two years
I've ever seen in my life that I
disagree with but it's obviously what he
has to say
loser loser loser
now we're getting going
it'll be different this time why
why will it be different this time those
arguments need to be made
and I'm not afraid to make them this is
the only guy who's actually saying this
stuff why why won't Tim Scott do this
why won't DeSantis do this why they are
all weak other than Chris Christie he's
polling 1.3 percent we'll see where it
goes Donald Trump has been looking for a
new defense lawyer even as late as this
morning just hours before today's arrest
booking and arraignment this is
unbelievable stuff report from The
Washington Post Trump scrambles to find
lawyer before First Federal court
appearance what is happening Donald
Trump spent the day before his historic
appearance in federal court
scrambling to find a qualified Florida
lawyer willing to join his defense team
as he faces the Justice Department's
first prosecution of a former president
this is yesterday after touching down in
Miami Monday Trump spent the afternoon
interviewing prospective lawyers and
meeting with his legal team along with
other top advisors to discuss the case
in which as you know he's accused of
mishandling classified documents
obstruction Etc several prominent
Florida attorneys declined to take Trump
on as a client after two of the key
lawyers handling the document matter Jim
trustee and John Rowley resigned last
week a trump advisor said late Monday
Trump would be joined in court by Todd
Blanche an attorney handling his case in
New York as well as veteran Florida
litigator Christopher kais on the Troth
Central platform Trump said last week
Blanche would lead his defense team
along with a firm to be named later this
is not good this is very much not good
for Trump the article goes on to say
trustee and rowley's departure was
sudden and unexpected leaving Trump
jocking to identify a lawyer ahead of
today's appearance in federal court
where rules require practicing attorneys
to be members in good standing of the
Florida bar or be sponsored by one
before appearing kais led the search for
a lawyer and cast a seemingly wide net
he declined to comment the 11th Hour
flurry to hire a seasoned trial attorney
was a familiar dance for Trump who has
had difficulty hiring and keeping
lawyers over the course of federal and
state investigations disagreements over
legal strategy hindered this search for
new defense attorneys this is wild wild
stuff that this is unbelievable in a
normal World attorneys would be
qualified attorneys would be falling all
over themselves to defend a former
president in an unprecedented situation
but they are probably becoming aware
that when you tell Trump uncomfortable
truths like the indictment is strong or
mistakes have been made up until now and
we are now digging out or you might have
to plea in some way
Trump probably loses his mind it's
unclear whether these lawyers would even
be able to get paid so in a sense in a
situation where lawyers should be
desperate to work with Trump
it's fascinating that there are even
lawyers still willing to represent Trump
and it's probably a small subset of
people who are like smart enough to pass
the bar
but not clever enough to realize that
working with Trump in this capacity is
an impossibility because of the
difficulties in both collecting payment
and getting Trump to actually do what
you suggest that he does and we've
talked before about Maga really means
making attorneys get attorneys that's
been a theme as well the smartest
possible interpretation of this entire
lawyer thing would be Trump is staging a
difficulty in finding lawyers as a delay
tactic to continually be able to have
lawyers say to a court hey I was just
brought on I need a delay in order to
familiarize myself with the facts of the
case and then you switch again and again
and again there is that's that's the
most generous interpretation there is
absolutely no evidence that that's
actually what's going on this is a wild
situation where Trump is struggling to
find lawyers even hours before today's
court appearance will be live for the
arraignment and the arrest and the
entire thing on YouTube twitch and
Facebook and I hope hope you'll join me
one more note about the classified
document bathroom dump that took place
at Mar-A-Lago Speaker of the House Kevin
McCarthy a republican was asked it
really doesn't look good right for Trump
to have classified documents in his
bathroom
and McCarthy actually said bathrooms
have lockable doors and actually brought
up Joe Biden this is you would think
this were a joke they're not really
going to do this are they here is Kevin
McCarthy defending documents in the
bathroom was that a good look for the
former president to have boxes
all the time a bathroom door locks
so what is he referring to this is the
story of how Joe Biden had documents in
his garage next to his Corvette
the stupidity of this is you can't just
lift the garage door from the outside
like that's not how garage doors work
but the argument that Kevin McCarthy is
making is bathrooms have lockable doors
but garages don't now it's of course
untrue it's also kind of silly because
bathrooms have lockable doors from the
inside I don't re I mean listen they
were getting really into the weeds here
but usually if you lock the bathroom
door from the outside you're what we
would call locked out many of the doors
with a little pin you can unlock it from
the outside so is that even really
secure but we're at the level the point
here is the following it's not about
lock smithery it's about Kevin McCarthy
is trying to defend the indefensible in
the same way that these Republicans have
been doing it now for a while which is
to either talk about Hillary Clinton or
in this particular case to talk about
Joe Biden it is laughable but it is not
unexpected we have a cult that is what
this is and Kevin McCarthy defending the
bathroom dump you got to see it to
believe it
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
today we're going to be speaking with
Rhys Peck who's an associate professor
at the City University of New York and
also author of the book Fox populism
branding conservatism as working class
really appreciate your time and for
being here today
yeah my pleasure so to start with you
know my um my understanding of the
history of political media uh including
sort of as described by the book waves
of rancor which starts with the use of
low power FM and talk radio and and sort
of all the way through where we are now
is that the political right and the
political left have used media
differently part of that has to do with
ownership structure and issues related
to money and financing but part of it
also has to do with the right quite
frankly having better I would argue more
effective sort of bumper sticker phrases
that better lend themselves to some
forms of media can you talk a little bit
about the current landscape and how you
would sort of distinguish the way the
political right and left use media
yeah well first off the right it's hard
to talk about the kind of right versus
left media you really have to think
about a kind of a liberal corporatist
Center that dominates the mainstream
Legacy Media and then this massive
right-wing sector that's always been
there for multiple generations and then
this little sliver of truly leftist
media and these alternative spaces so
you kind of have to break it down on a
tripartite uh model it's harder to talk
about like left media versus liberal
Centrist media
um but the left media uh in terms of the
history of alternative left media I mean
today there's a common sense notion that
the mainstream media is liberal as a
liberal bias but if you took a time
machine to the 1930s when they talked
about the bias of the press it was
always the capitalist press or the
conservative press and so labor unions
and leftists had to create these
alternative Revenue models had to kind
of fight their way to get on radio
and it's always been this uphill uphill
battle I mean if you're critical of
capitalism and the media system you
exist in is commercial in nature right
um it's an uphill battle for funding for
legitimacy uh and so that's largely the
history of the left like the true left
kind of alternative media the
conservative media uh inversely I guess
would say when you have this
pro-business class uh free market
ideology the wins that you're back right
you're basically telling media
Executives and billionaire donors that
they're the moral history I mean they're
the moral Heroes they're the job
creators so they're going to look kindly
on you and your in your content uh and
so but I don't think that structural
analysis it can only go so far and I
think leftists throw their hands in the
air and they say well we don't have the
same billionaire backing we don't have
the same funding and I think you're very
right to say there are things in which
left media creators do to tie their own
hands to shoot themselves in the foot in
terms of messaging in terms of style in
terms of narrative that that has really
catapulted the right is it I completely
agree with you they're kind of more
sophisticated in terms of their
communication and media strategies can
you talk a little bit give some examples
of that and you know I mean when I talk
to others in the left media space and
when I talk about that just to be really
clear I'm not talking about MSNBC MSNBC
is sort of like a Democratic Party
Center left positioning corporate profit
motives that are identical to Fox News
Etc even if some of their policies are
different certainly their editorial
perspective is different but when I talk
to other people in like left Independent
Media there are many who say I would
gladly accept the millionaire or even
billionaire donors of the daily wire if
they came to me and said hey I want to
give you money to do exactly what you're
doing the Counterpoint to that is those
who say no no no no by the very nature
of having those millionaires or
billionaires supporting you you would
not be able to do what you're doing
that's the difference between what the
left wants to espouse and what the right
wants to espouse so how much of it is
that the messaging of the left is not
appealing to those monied interests
versus something else
well I would say that there was no
shortage of millionaire billionaire uh
money for right-wing media in the 1950s
and 60s and 70s but they were not nearly
as successful and so if it was all money
and donations then how come William F
Buckley wasn't you know a kind of
populist tabloid hit or how come the
first generation the conservatives were
so ineffective their media before
Limbaugh before Fox News was largely on
the margins it was a boutique kind of
segment of the conservative movement uh
it was only when you get to Limbaugh
where you see this blend of kind of
profitability they're they're a
profitable commercial entertainment
product and then conservative ideology
and it's when the conservatives really
with Murdoch's influence Embraces
tabloid style in popular style and
integrated insights from tabloid the
public affairs genres like talk radio or
tablet television that the right attain
this kind of level of cultural dominance
and prevalence that it did and so I
think there's lessons to be learned from
the left right the left has this
inflexible commitment to this kind of
upper middle class educated uh imagined
audience in mind when they're when
they're designing their style they're
designing their kind of consumer appeals
and they're averse to this tabloid uh
aesthetic they're averse to kind of
populist modes of Engagement and I think
that's you know the the success of the
ride is largely a story with them
shifting toward a different style that's
more conducive to mass taste and and
kind of working class uh identity so
going back like what are the stylistic
mistakes that you think the left is
making that limit the appeal
well I think the left in especially when
you know there was this coming to Jesus
moment when uh George W bush won his
second term and and that was when you
see this explosion of kind of anti-fox
Media Ventures we got to do something
about Fox you get you know air America
is launched you know you get uh Jon
Stewart kind of coming in into his own
and critiquing and then you get a um you
know Oberman a little later and so
there's this moment where they're like
we need an Unapologetic kind of form of
progressive media to counter what fox is
doing I think my critique there is they
went all in on sarcasm and comedy in
this kind of ironic style that was the
way they were going to be popular
appealing and that has its uses and we
all like to a degree the satirical style
but I think it's limited when you have
other ways you can speak to people with
sincerity with emotional expressiveness
with recruiting certain personalities
that don't come from Prestige sectors of
the journal isn't filled and that's
exactly what fox did MSNBC had a slight
moment of flirtation with popular styled
hosts with Jake Huger and Dylan radicand
and Ed Schultz uh and those shows did
good they they were they they had pretty
good ratings but it was I would say it's
because of their middle Brown taste
culture that it was off brand with MSNBC
they were trying to appeal to this
educated affluent uh demographic and
they didn't want to
um you know uh alienate them with this
populist sensibility uh and so I think
that that that's the key to me and every
time the left kind of plays with this
they generally abandon those kind of
hosts those kind of styles
George lakov has a perspective where
media aside
he argues that some of the arguments of
the right are just structurally better
suited to commercial media like a couple
examples would be hey abortion's murder
so it should be banned and on the left
it's like well you know we've got to
talk about viability and then you have
to understand sort of like the 40-week
pregnancy and uh mammalian gestation and
we have to draw it's not like a good
bumper sticker phrase or hey the taxes
it's my money let me keep my money
whereas the left is like well yes once
societies get large enough some roles
need to be centralized and so we have to
find the right tact right it's like so
he makes a more Linguistics or that that
sort of approach is how how important is
that versus like strategic media
decisions that are made by left and
right
I think it's critical you know I'm not
you know lakov the insides of lakehoff
is that the first way we interface with
politics is often through these moral
registers it's not through these like
Nuance policy discussions or what the
facts are we really start with
Aesthetics and moral frames and then we
move to the policies those things it's
not that those things don't matter it's
just the way in which people interface
and the sequencing that they they kind
of come to engage in politics through
and and I and I I agree I mean there's
other civil rights leaders like uh
Reverend Barber who's excellent he's
he's been calling for the progressives
to develop what he calls a kind of
universal moral language and it doesn't
mean when you speak in these moral terms
you have to abandon Nuance or complexity
it's just to recognize that that is
engaging from the from up front right
that you're really laying out these kind
of positions and the right is really
good at recognizing not just speaking in
a moralistic way but recognizing what
moral political stories have had
resonance over time all right they're
very good at looking at like you just
mentioned
um this idea that I work hard and I
deserve the fruits of my labor right
there's there's a way you could frame
that in a left-wing way yeah the labor
movement works hard and they're they're
the ones that create wealth right you
could use that same moral frame like FDR
did but the right captures it co-ops and
then turns that into a story about the
fruits of Labor is really giving these
business people and the job creators
like all their hard work and so we need
not to tax them because they're the most
productive segments of society so the
ride is like very Savvy at recognizing
which narratives have resonated and been
recycled over political history and
where the left kind of shuns these
things and what the name of the
intellectual complexity or that it's too
hokey or corny
um and I just think that again that's
another way and yet they're they're
shooting themselves in the foot what do
you make strategically about the recent
Focus From the Republican party in Media
on the culture War stuff and he woke the
trans issues you know men and women's
sports as they like to call it Etc you
know a lot of the rhetoric is the same
rhetoric that was assigned to gay men 10
years ago that has just moved on now and
taken a little bit of a different tone
but do you think that from a media
studies perspective
um that it is a logical thing for the
right to be doing
temporarily or even on the medium term
or is it a mistake strategically
it all depends on if you know Murdoch
has always been very good at taking
something that seems
um uh you know somewhat Petty like
Eminem's being having you know uh you
know androgynous boots on or something
like that and everyone on the last the
left laughs at it right we're like oh
it's so ridiculous they care about these
little things but it's the way in which
they'll take something that is palpable
and mundane and every day and connect it
to the broader world of politics and
that actually makes politics more
palpable gives it texture and so they're
only successful if they just get two in
the weeds with CTO with CRT and trans
issues and don't connect it to these
broader narratives about how liberals
look down on us and they're part of the
educated Elite and they're the
campus-based crowd and we're the working
class crowd that's when those kind of
cultural War narratives hats pack their
biggest punch but it's it's like when I
look at the santis for example he just
lacks that ability to take those issues
and kind of turn them into Broad water
class narratives about elitism and about
we're on the side of authentic people
and normal people uh and he's just
overly online and it just seems like it
starts to seem like you're actually just
uh your your tactic is too naked you're
just scapegoating you're creating a
scapegoat for the sake of creating a
scapegoat and it doesn't feel like it
has as broad or populous message where
Trump is very good at exploiting those
class cultural tensions between the
college educated and the non-college
educated class so I think that's where
they they're the best is when they can
package it in some sort of larger
populist class critique it's at its
worst when it just is nakedly bigoted
and nakedly
um uh uh a kind of subculture of the
right that they're obsessed with an
extreme kind of religious subculture
speaking of like the online media Space
versus kind of like outside of it one of
the conversations I had with my audience
during the 2020 Democratic primary was
that spending a lot of time on Twitter
and Reddit would likely give you uh uh
an over emphasized perspective on how
popular Bernie Sanders is within the
Democratic party and I had the belief
and I think there was polling to Bear it
out that people who are just like
working in Michigan and then picking up
their kids and going home they're not
necessarily on Twitter and Reddit in the
same way if they're on it at all and
that Joe Biden's support among the
Democratic party voters is likely much
higher than it seems and this seemed to
be the case now yes to some degree there
was this coordinated everybody got out
of Joe Biden's way after South Carolina
like that's that's true but I think the
point kind of Still Remains there has
this online discourse actually become
deceptive in terms of figuring out what
quote what people care about maybe not
only on the left but also on the right
in the sense that I don't know that that
many Republican voters the sorts of
people that kind of want like a Chris
Christie or a Mitt Romney are that
engaged with like the so-called men and
women's sports thing or the anti-woke
has online really distorted what people
care about
I mean I think undeniably you know I
think that what when you really get to
the 2016 election which is really this
important pivotal shift I think in our
media culture and our politics where you
know you're no longer you know seeing
Obama dance with Ellen Degeneres and and
Hillary Clinton you know goes on stage
with Beyonce it's like this is that old
kind of monoculture model right the
vestiges of the network era where you
could still do that kind of politics
what we see in 2016 is the online
fringes start to emerge and have
outsized influence kind of erasing this
Normie kind of middle brow political uh
center right and and so you it's it
creates this deception that they're
bigger or they're more representative of
both uh their respective political sides
than they actually are and I think
you're right I I kind of was guilty of
that too when you when you consume
Bernie kind of align media so much you
know when the 2020 election happened I
realized that there are people that are
actually have much more cemented demo
pro-democratic party Normie loyalties uh
MSNBC and CNN actually did have some
power regardless of all the calls that
they're dying they're dead they're
relevant yeah you know I think they show
they're still kind of shaping what your
average middle of the road Democratic
voter thinks
um and so I'm with you I mean I think
there is
um there is an overconfidence sometimes
with the kind of alternative political
media spheres but with that said uh it
is undeniable that people are cord
cutting it's undeniable that cable is in
Decline and that even it's the writing's
on the wall even those organizations
have tried to do an over-the-top
streaming model Fox Nation CNN plus uh
they're seeing how the independent
alternative sphere is getting larger and
larger and larger and will be more
political influence so I think we're in
this moment of transition right so it's
hard to prognosticate like what's what
or who's listening to who who's driving
the agenda
um it's much more unclear than it was
back in 2008 or even at the beginning of
2016. that's for sure
we've been speaking with associate
professor at the City University of New
York Reese Peck also author of the book
Fox populism branding conservatism as
working class Reese really appreciate
your time and insights today
thank you thank you for having me
subscribe to our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show watch
the full hour-long show individual Clips
all of our interviews and everything
else from the show and when you
subscribe make sure to click that Bell
button to be notified about every new
video
Maga is indeed melting down today the
day of Donald Trump's second arrest and
indictment this one federally in Miami
Florida by the time you listen to
Today's show it may have already
happened and we will of course have full
live coverage today as well as of
Trump's Bedminster speech at 8 15 PM
Eastern tonight hope you'll join me for
that and then we will debrief tomorrow
but let's take a quick tour through
magaland here is a former Trump
propaganda Steve Bannon who recently
attacked me and called me brother Dave
Pacman this guy is not my brother he is
now turning on William Barr William Barr
Trump's former Attorney General of
course saying if half of the indictment
is true Trump is toast we looked at that
clip yesterday and here is Steve Bannon
he's using profanity guys so that's how
you know he means business and Bill Barr
you can sit up there and say it's a
great case we're going to shove this up
your ass okay we're gonna shove it up
your ass you're you're you are freaking
guilty of treason big old you're guilty
of treason and raised guilty of treason
there is no evidence whatsoever that
William Barr has committed treason there
is no evidence whatsoever that FBI
director chosen by Trump Christopher Ray
has committed treason and I will remind
you one of the big selling points that
Trump listed about himself was that he
would hire the best people always the
best people and he hired two Traders he
hired William Barr a Trader and
Christopher Ray a Trader it doesn't say
very much about Trump's ability to
select employees which was one of the
big selling points we go now from Steve
Bannon to Kerry Lake Carrie lake is also
using an extreme filter filter on her
camera she is talking about how the NRA
comments she made how there are NRA
members who will stand between I guess
the justice department and Trump it's
not a threat she says it's not a threat
sure sounds like a threat to me take a
listen if they think they're going to
hurt lay a finger on our president
president Trump they're going to have to
come through me and I made a mistake I
said 75 million others just like me I
think it's more like 300 million others
just like me the people in this country
who support president there aren't even
300 million adults in the United States
what is she talking about President
Trump who know what's up who know that
that botched election was an attempt to
prevent him from getting in office and
cleaning up the corruption in our
country and I said I said as an aside
and most of us are NRA members that is
not a threat that is a public service
announcement it certainly sounds like a
threat and if you want to see exactly
what it leads to
freedomnews.tv interviewed Pat a trump
supporter who said January 6th is going
to look like a playground compared to I
guess what he's willing to do in Miami
later today
this is serious folks listen to this a
lot of my family blood spilled for this
country I'm not gonna let it go to waste
I'm not I refuse I did 19 years here as
a federal agent in Dade County
um
I'm just not going to let this country
go to waste and right now it's going to
waste well if he gets indoctrinated
January 6 is going to look like a
playground I assume he means indicted
I assume when Pat says indoctrinated he
means indicted
it's going to look like a playground
from the inside voices that I hear from
all the militias and everything else
it's going to be a playground but if
they want to fight bring it I mean I've
been in I watch Kamala Harris in Orlando
I watched antifa throw bottles spit on
my child
throw stuff at us they told us to
refrain ourselves really what okay but
it is what it is you know this country's
so left right now but we got to bring it
back to the right we got to get right on
the right path we got to bring
everything back if we don't we're going
to crumble
be a third
world the when the I'm telling you guys
when the world sees this this will lead
to our viewers from Germany and from the
UK and from France and from Finland and
from Sweden I'm going to get emails
saying David what is wrong with the
country what is happening there we have
to stand up for that flag we have to
stand up for our beliefs
we got to put God back in this country
if we forget about him he's going to
forget about us and right now we're
forgetting him and we're forgetting
Israel we forget both of those
let's read your Bible
read your Bible because there's a lot of
boys like me that are ready right all we
need is an order we're ready believe
everything they need an order and they
are ready here's one more person they're
talking to I guess
okay no they're not okay that's the end
of the interview let's hope for no
violence today that is my hope the last
thing we need on top of any of this is
to Cloud
what should be
a political
justice department actions
and court cases with the violence of
these unhinged people that's my hope
that we do not see violence today
we have yet another former Trump staffer
saying this is serious and Trump may end
up in prison here is Mick Mulvaney
Donald Trump's own former Chief of Staff
previous to uh Mark Meadows
saying Trump indeed may end up doing
prison time I don't even agree with this
but this is Mick Mulvaney himself saying
it if Donald Trump had done what Joe
Biden did here what Mike Pence did here
when they found their classified
documents they gave them back and
there's no charges against Pence there's
not going to be charges against Biden
the difference here is what Trump did to
try and cover up what he did in the
first place I said so often the case
it's not the underlying crime it's the
interference it's the cover-up that gets
folks in trouble and they have him with
significant evidence it looks like as to
obstruction so I think the chances of a
of a guilty verdict are fairly High and
the chances of of real jail time are
pretty high and when you say real jail
time how long might that be
well at his age it doesn't really make
much difference right I think the
maximum if you add up all the math the
maximum could be over 500 years the
minimum would be a hundred years
I don't even think I agree with Mick
Mulvaney and I've said all along I don't
believe Donald Trump will do a day of
prison time period however I will say
that over the last 72 hours
I have moved ever so slightly in the
direction of
maybe maybe there will be some jail time
for Trump it's it's I I'm now in the
realm of before I was in absolutely no
way in hell
after speaking to a couple of lawyers
reading through the indictment reading
uh uh about the law around the
allegations for which Trump is going to
be charged looking at a few different
things I am now I've moved from no way
in hell Trump does prison time to it is
extremely unlikely but possible that
Trump ends up with something it could
however end up being one of these well
he will serve it at his house with an
ankle monitor which by the way I would
still accept at this point in time all
right so Mick Mulvaney also now on the
list of former Trump staffers who says
this is serious and Trump could be toast
to quote William Barr we'll see who else
comes out of the woodwork we have a
voicemail number that you can call any
time of day that number's 2192 David P
we receive political questions at this
number
we receive trolling we receive insults
and attacks on me we receive
anti-semitic comments we also sometimes
receive interesting questions like the
following about raising bilingual
children listen to this
hi Mr Pacman this is Anne from Long
Island yes I'm calling to get your
opinion about raising bilingual children
where I live there's a lot of central
Americans and as many of them as there
are there are equal number of opinions
about what is the best way to have
bilingual kids right
um I read one time that one parent
should speak in one language and the
other a different language
so um I just was interested in your
opinion thank you bye okay this has
absolutely nothing to do with the
typical content of this show my opinion
is based on what I've read and people
I've spoken to that indeed one of the
best ways to raise a child bilingual is
for each parent to exclusively speak a
particular language with the child this
is what we are doing with my daughter I
only speak to my daughter in Spanish and
uh so far it's working fine uh it's very
cool she says some words in English and
Spanish she very clearly understands the
things I say to her in Spanish as
evidenced by you know if I tell her to
wave in Spanish she'll wave or ask her
about do you want to turn on my espresso
machine and she points at it this is
what we're doing and then the next thing
may be like when daycare starts a full
Spanish Immersion daycare so that that's
what I'm doing I can't speak to the
linguistic justification for it it's
just what I've been told and what I read
we'll see how it works out right ask me
in five years okay we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
student loan payments are scheduled to
start again in October
and this has generated a lot of
confusion among some we'll talk about
what is happening we will talk about the
strategy some had to wait it out and all
of it secondly Illinois is looking to
ban book bands and they have indeed uh
Governor pritzker there signed a bill
into law that does a lot to ban bans on
books we will discuss it and lastly a
woman believed dead was found breathing
in a coffin at her own funeral this is
like a nightmare scenario that people
have bad dreams about quite literally
nightmares about I have friends who have
talked to me about this
it happened apparently we will discuss
it and much more on today's bonus show
remember that you can get instant access
to the bonus show you don't have to go
through any kind of long process like
for a passport or for citizenship or a
green card in a minute you can sign up
at joinpakman.com and you will instantly
get access to that which angers Alex
Jones so much oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad that is exactly right that is
absolutely and exactly right
joinpakman.com get the bonus show join
me live today for both live streams
related to Trump's arrest and then we'll
have another program for you tomorrow
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the world's best
guides to non-fiction books come from
our sponsor short form short form offers
comprehensive coverage to thousands of
top non-fiction books so you can learn
more faster unlike other summary
Services their guides provide valuable
insights counter arguments and analyzes
for a well-rounded understanding of the
topic try it free and get 25 off using
my link below